POSSIBLY.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY,
THE CRAZY DEMOCRATS EXPOSE,
RECOGNIZE -- THE GREAT ONE MARK
LEVAN -- I JUST CHECKED IN WITH
HIM, HE IS FIRED UP AND HE WILL
BE JOINING US TONIGHT.
LARA TRUMP JOINS US TONIGHT, SO
MANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN ASKING --
WE HAVE THE HISTORY -- TWO DAYS
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
ELECTED, IMPEACHMENT STARTED ALL
THROUGH 2017, 2018, 2019 -- WE
GOT IT ALL COVERED.
WE CAN'T PLATE EVERY NIGHT
BECAUSE IT TAKES TOO LONG.
THAT IS COMING UP.
PLUS MYSTERY SURROUNDING THE
IDENTITY OF THE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER -- HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO KICKED OFF
THIS INSANE NEW UKRAINIAN
WITCH HUNT.
ONE REPORT, REAL CLEAR
INVESTIGATIONS OF REAL CLEAR
POLITICS CLAIMING A TRUMP HATING
DEEP STATE OPERATIVE WITH CLOSE
TIES TO JOE BIDEN AND TRUMP
HAYTER FORMER CIA DIRECTOR, THE
CORRUPT BRENDAN AND THE STAFFERS
WORKING FOR THE COMPROMISED,
CORRUPT CONGENITAL LIAR
ADAM SCHIFF.
REPORTS HE ALSO HAS TIES TO THE
VERY SAME DNC OPERATIVE THAT
HELPED THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN,
WENT TO THE UKRAINIAN EMBASSY TO
GET DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
ASSOCIATES AND COORDINATED AND
COLLUDED WITH UKRAINE TO IMPACT
THE 2016 ELECTION.
WE ARE NOW LOOKING DOWN THE
BARREL OF YET ANOTHER NATIONAL
CRISIS CLEARLY ORCHESTRATED BY
THE DEEP STATE, A HIT JOB THAT
WILL NOT GO UNCHALLENGED.
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR HERE
TONIGHT.
ON THIS PROGRAM, WE ARE GOING TO
WAIT, WE ALWAYS GET NEW PROCESS
AND PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE, WE
AREN'T GOING TO REVEAL A
PERSON'S IDENTITY THAT EVERYBODY
IN WASHINGTON IS TALKING ABOUT
UNTIL WE CAN INDEPENDENTLY
CONFIRM THE FACTS, ALSO
BREAKING MOMENTS AGO, ANOTHER
STAR WITNESS IN THE SECRET
SOVIET STYLE IMPEACHMENT TO
ATTEMPT JUST OBLITERATED THE
DEMOCRATS NARRATIVE, THAT'S WHY
THEY ARE DOING IT BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS.
I TALKED TO MY SOURCES, ANOTHER
DISASTROUS DAY FOR DEMOCRATS AND
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE STAYING
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, THAT'S WHY
THEY ARE USING THE SOVIET STYLE
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDING AND
DEMOCRATS ARE ALL GIDDY --
REMEMBER LIEUTENANT COLONEL
VINDMAN'S INTERPRETATION OF THE
CALL?
WE DON'T NEED HIS
INTERPRETATION, HIS BOSS
TESTIFIED TODAY AND LITERALLY
OBLITERATED AND BLASTED HIS
INTERPRETATION AND A STORY OUT
OF THE WATER TODAY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, DESTROYED THE PHONY
LIE AND NARRATIVE THAT THE MOB
AND MEDIA HAS BEEN PUSHING WITH
THE TRANSCRIPT WAS CHANGED.
TOP NATIONAL SECURITY OFFICIAL,
HE WAS THE BOSS -- HIS NAME WAS
TIM MORRISON, HE TESTIFIED
NOTHING ILLEGAL TOOK PLACE
DURING THE PRESIDENT'S CALL WITH
UKRAINE.
"I WANT TO BE CLEAR, I WAS NOT
CONCERNED THAT ANYTHING ILLEGAL
WASN'T DISCUSSED.
HE ALSO INTERESTINGLY SAID THE
TRANSCRIPT ACCURATELY AND
COMPLETELY REFLECTS THE
SUBSTANCE OF THE CALL.
THAT BLOWS THE WHOLE THING OUT
OF THE WATER.
MORRISON REPORTEDLY TESTIFIED HE
WAS CONCERNED OF THE CONTENTS OF
THE CALL WOULD BE LEAKED TO THE
MEDIA, SHOCKING FOR PRETTY GOOD
REASON BECAUSE ONLY THIS
PRESIDENT HAS ALREADY HAD
MULTIPLE CONVERSATIONS -- WITH
PRIME MINISTERS, PRESIDENTS,
HEADS OF STATE -- LEAKED.
THIS HAS NOT HAPPENED TO ANY
OTHER PRESIDENT SO OF COURSE HE
WAS SUSPICIOUS.
YOU WOULD THINK THIS TESTIMONY
FROM A KEY TOP OFFICIAL WOULD
CAUSE AT LEAST SOME OF THE
SO-CALLED MODERATE DEMOCRATS TO
PUT THE BRAKES ON THE
IMPEACHMENT MADNESS AND
PSYCHOSIS AND RAGE AGAINST
TRUMP, TODAY DESPITE MORRISON'S
REMARKS, ONLY TWO DEMOCRATS
VOTED TO GIVE A GREEN LIGHT TO
THE CORRUPT COMPROMISE AND
THAT'S WHO ADAM SCHIFF IS,
CONGENITAL LIAR -- HE HAS BEEN
LYING TO US FOR THREE YEARS.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF ONE
CONGRESSMAN NAMED
COLLIN PETERSON AND JEFF
VAN DREW, EVERY OTHER DEMOCRAT,
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT LIST.
THOSE FROM SWING DISTRICTS,
DISTRICTS THAT TRUMP WON, THEY
VOTED TO GO ALONG WITH THIS
MADNESS WITH ZERO TWO
MADNESS WITH ZERO DWO
MADNESS WITH ZERO DUE PROCESS,
LEADING THE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
WITCH HUNT.
MANY OF THE LAWMAKERS ON YOUR
SCREEN THEY ALL RAN ON A
PARTISAN PLATFORM, A BIPARTISAN
PLATFORM, THEY WANT TO REACH
ACROSS THE AISLE AND WORK
TOGETHER AND FOCUS ON FIXING AND
HELPING THE LIVES OF AMERICANS.
SOME EVEN SAID IMPEACHMENT IS A
REALLY BAD IDEA BUT THEY WENT
ALONG ANYWAY.
PUSH CAME TO SHOVE AND THEIR
ARMS WERE TWISTED BY PELOSI AND
COMPANY AND THE SQUAD, THEY
CAVED, EVERY ONE OF THEM -- TAKE
A LOOK.
>> IT'S ABOUT BOTH SIDES BEING
WILLING TO ACTUALLY SAY WE ARE
GOING TO PUT ASIDE OUR POLITICAL
LABELS FOR A MINUTE AND FOCUS ON
WHAT IS BEST -- WE ARE AMERICANS
FIRST.
>> WE NEED TO BE LOOKING FOR
SOLUTIONS, BIPARTISAN SOLUTIONS.
WHEN I GET TO WASHINGTON, I'M
GOING TO DO WHAT JOHN F. KENNEDY
SAID, WE SHOULDN'T BE LOOKING
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC ANSWER OR THE
REPUBLICAN ANSWER, WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING FOR THE RIGHT ANSWER.
>> WE NEED TO BE WORKING
TOGETHER DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, I DON'T THINK IT'S
THAT HARD.
>> I DIDN'T GET ELECTED TO SPEND
THE NEXT 18 MONTHS ON THE
POLITICAL PROCESS OF
IMPEACHMENT.
>> Sean: WORDS ARE CHEAP, THEY
ALL FOLDED, THEY ALL LIED TO
THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
THE PEOPLE YOU SAW, THEY GAVE
INTO THE PRESSURE, THEY ARE
CON ARTISTS, THEY AREN'T WORKING
FOR THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
INSTEAD THEY ALWAYS HOLD THE
PARTY LINE AND WHATEVER SCHIFF
AND PELOSI IN THE SQUAD WANTS
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO
VOTE FOR.
THEY ALL CAVED AND VOTED AND
GAVE THIS INCREDIBLE IMPEACHMEN
IMPEACHMENT -- CONGENITAL LIAR,
HE HAS TOTAL CONTROL THAT NOT.
HE'S BEEN LYING FOR THREE YEARS,
THEY DID THIS DESPITE HAVING NO
PUBLIC ACCESS TO ANY EVIDENCE,
NO HEARINGS, NO TRANSCRIPTS, NO
DUE PROCESS.
THESE ARE THE RULES, UNDER
NEWT GINGRICH DURING BILL
CLINTON'S IMPEACHMENT, HE
AFFORDED BILL CLINTON -- THE
HOUSE OPENLY DEBATED, THEY HELD
AN OFFICIAL VOTE, THE PRESIDENT
HAD THE ABILITY TO CALL
WITNESSES, BUILD A CASE AND HE
HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO EVERY
WITNESS BUT THE CORRUPT
COMPROMISED SCHIFF HAS COMPLETE
VETO POWER, LIKE A DICTATOR.
HE CAN CONTROL THE WITNESS LIST,
THE EVIDENCE AND THERE'S NOTHING
YOU CAN DO.
NO FAIR HEARINGS, NO ABILITY TO
MOUNT ANY DEFENSE, NO RIGHTS OF
THE ACCUSED -- WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT THE CHARGES ARE.
SCHIFF LYING TO US FOR ALL THESE
YEARS, HE'S A JUDGE, JURY, AND
EXECUTIONER AND WHAT IS ONLY A
PUBLIC SHOW TRIAL TO DECIDE TO
CONVINCE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
PRESIDENT DESERVES TO BE
IMPEACHED.
WE ARE TOLD THE MAJORITY OF
WITNESSES HAD HEARD NOTHING
WRONG WITH THE CALL THAT WE HAVE
A TRANSCRIPT TO BUT THEY AREN'T
GOING TO BE ASKED TO TESTIFY
PUBLICLY.
WATCH AND SEE, THAT'S HOW
CORRUPT HE IS.
THIS IS THE SOVIET UNION STYLE
ON STEROIDS, SO FAR IT HAS ALL
BEEN CONDUCTED IN SECRET BY A
GUY THAT IS A FACT WITNESS AND
COMPROMISED IN THE VERY CASE
CAUGHT IN MORE LIES AND I CAN
EVEN EDIT COUNT.
A GUY WHO WAS A TOTALLY
COMPROMISED INDIVIDUAL HIMSELF.
WE KNOW THEY WERE COORDINATING
WITH THE NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING -- THAT IS JUST A
FACT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT WAS
SAID, WAS HE ADVISED TO GO TO
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL?
LIKE WE SAID, THERE ARE REPORTS
REVEALING THAT THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S NAME AND
IDENTITY WAS ANTI-TRUMP, PRO
BIDEN, A DEEP STATE OPERATIVE,
FRIENDS WITH BRENDAN WITH A
PENCHANT FOR LEAKING.
ON THIS PROGRAM WE ARE GOING TO
INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY ALL OF THE
INFORMATION BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW
ALREADY IT'S CHILLING.
PARTISAN DEMOCRAT COLLUDED WITH
SCHIFF'S OFFICE, WE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED.
THIS INDIVIDUAL SUPPORTS BIDEN
AND WORKED FOR BRENNAN -- WE ARE
GOING TO LEARN A LOT ABOUT
BRENNAN.
WE ARE LEARNING A LOT ABOUT
BRENDAN IN THE DAYS AND WEEKS TO
COME.
REPUBLICANS MUST DEMAND ANSWERS,
THEY MUST DEMAND TO KNOW THE
EXTENT OF THIS PERSON'S CONTACT
WITH SCHIFF'S OFFICE, THEY MUST
DEMAND TO KNOW IF HE ABUSED HIS
POWER, THEY MUST DEMAND ANSWERS
ON HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH BIDEN,
BRENDAN, THE DNC AND WHILE THEY
ARE AT, AMERICA NEEDS -- WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TRANSCRIPTS
RELEASED, I WANT THE TRANSCRIPT
OF EVERY CALL WITH SLEEPY
CREEPY, CRAZY UNCLE JOE BIDEN.
THAT WAS THE GUY WHO WAS
INVOLVED WITH A REAL QUID PRO
QUO IN UKRAINE.
WE WANT EVERY CALL BETWEEN
BARACK HUSSEIN OBAMA AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN AFTER OBAMA
PROMISED MORE FLEXIBILITY AFTER
HIS ELECTION.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE THE
TRANSCRIPTS OF THE CALLS BETWEEN
OBAMA AND IRANIAN LEADERS
LEADING UP TO OBAMA MAKING THE
DUMBEST DEAL IN THE HISTORY OF
MANKIND GIVING THE RADICAL
MULLAHS OF IRAN THE CHANT "DEATH
TO AMERICA, DEATH TO ISRAEL"
HUNDRED $50 BILLION.
IT'S TIME FOR FAIRNESS.
WE NEED TO DEMAND THOSE
TRANSCRIPTS, WHAT'S FAIR IS
FAIR, RIGHT?
REGARDLESS OF THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S IDENTITY, THE
ONGOING WITCH HUNT SUPPORTED BY
ALL BUT TWO DEMOCRATS, IT'S ONLY
THE LATEST IN WHAT HAS BEEN A
THREE YEAR LAWLESS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BITTERLY
PARTISAN COUP ATTEMPT.
THEY HAVE NEVER ACCEPTED THE
ELECTION RESULTS, NOR THAT THEY
EXCEPT FOR CODE SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT PROVED IN
SPITE OF WHAT THEY WERE TELLING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THERE WAS
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
THEY IGNORED THE DOSSIER OF
HILLARY THE WHOLE TIME.
DEVOID OF ANY JUSTICE, TOTALLY
ATTACHED FROM REALITY.
AMERICANS ARE FAIR-MINDED, THAT
I CAN SAY FOR CERTAINTY.
THEY WILL SEE THIS FOR WHAT IT
IS, THE CORRUPTION, THIS IS THE
FILTHIEST AND MOST REPULSIVE RAW
POLITICAL ACT THAT IN MY 31
YEARS OF DOING TALK RADIO AND MY
24TH YEAR HERE AT FOX THAT I
HAVE EVER SEEN.
A FEW MONTHS AGO, SPEAKER PELOSI
TOLD "THE WASHINGTON POST" --
KIND OF IRONIC -- "IMPEACHMENT
IS SO DIVISIVE TO THE COUNTRY
UNLESS THERE IS SOMETHING SO
COMPELLING AND OVERWHELMING AND
BIPARTISAN, I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD GO DOWN THAT PATH, IT
WILL DIVIDE THE COUNTRY."
ADAM SCHIFF SET UP A TIME "IF
THE EVIDENT ISN'T SUFFICIENT TO
WIN BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR THIS,
PUTTING THE COUNTRY THROUGH A
FAILED IMPEACHMENT IS NOT A GOOD
IDEA."
HE IS DOING IT.
JERROLD NADLER, "IMPEACHMENT
SHOULD NOT BE PARTISAN, IT'S
PARTISAN BECAUSE EVERY SINGLE
REPUBLICAN IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES STOOD UNITED AND
STRONG AGAINST THE PSYCHOSIS AND
INJUSTICE.
PELOSI, SCHIFF, NADLER LIED
AGAIN.
THEY ARE MAJOR-LEAGUE HYPOCRITES
CONTROLLED BY THE RADICAL
SOCIALIST BASE.
WITHOUT ANY DUE PROCESS AT ALL.
THE PSYCHOTIC RAGE FILLED
TRUMPETING DEMOCRATS WILL VOTE
TO IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP AND THE
PRESIDENT WILL BE VINDICATED IN
THE SENATE BY PROBABLY ALMOST
ALL THE SENATORS, IF NOT ALL OF
THEM.
WITHOUT DUE PROCESS, NOW THE
U.S. SENATE NEEDS TO SEND A VERY
LOUD MESSAGE TO THEIR CORRUPT
HOUSE COLLEAGUES AND TEACH THEM
A LESSON ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION.
IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO ALLOW DUE
PROCESS, WE WILL DISMISS THIS ON
DAY ONE.
THERE IS EVERY INDICATION THAT
WILL HAPPEN.
THE BEST PART IS TODAY, WE ARE
ONE YEAR AND THREE DAYS AWAY
FROM THE ELECTION.
THAT'S RIGHT, AND THAT MEANS
THAT WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, NOT
SCHIFF, NOT PELOSI, NOT THE
SQUAD, NOT AOC, YOU GET TO
DECIDE AND YOU GET TO REELECT
DONALD TRUMP.
THE PEOPLE WILL GET THEIR SAY.
WHO KNOWS WHAT THEY ARE CAPABLE
OF IN THE NEXT YEAR?
WE KNOW WHAT THEY DID BEFORE THE
LAST ELECTION AND AFTER THE LAST
ELECTION BUT THE TRUTH IS
ANYTHING BETWEEN NOW AND
NOVEMBER 2020 IS POLITICAL NOISE
AND POLITICAL THEATER, THEY HAVE
DONE NOTHING FOR YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE DONE NOTHING, THEY
HAVE JUST TRIED TO HATE TRUMP
HARDER AND HARDER EVERY DAY AND
THEY HAVE BEEN FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO GET WHAT THEY WANT.
SAD REALITY IS, AT THE
DEMOCRATS, THE MOB IN THE MEDIA,
THEIR ALLIES IN THE SWAMP, THEY
HAVE NEVER SUNK SO LOW.
IT SHOULD BE A SAD DAY FOR
AMERICA, I'M NOT SO SAD BECAUSE
I THINK ALL THEY ARE DOING IS
HELPING DONALD TRUMP, THEY ARE
BECOMING THE BIGGEST CONTRIBUTOR
TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, THE
REELECTION CAMPAIGN.
THEY HAVE COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY
DETACH THEMSELVES FROM REALITY,
THEIR SOLE MISSION SURROUNDS
THIS IRRATIONAL, PSYCHOTIC,
NEVER ENDING HATRED OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE MERE NAME
OF WHICH TRIGGERS THEM ALL.
THERE IS ALSO A DEEP HATRED FOR
WE THE PEOPLE, THE SMELLY
WALMART SHOPPERS, THE
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES THAT
CLING TO GOD, OUR GUNS, OUR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS, OUR
BIBLES AND RELIGION.
THERE IS A DEEP CONTEMPT FOR
AMERICANS.
THIS VOTE IS JUST THE LATEST
COUP ATTEMPT, ONE MIDDLE FINGER,
ONE MORE DERANGED SCREAM AND
YELL FROM A GROUP OF PEOPLE
THROWING A TEMPER TANTRUM
BECAUSE THEY LOST AND NEVER
ACCEPTED THE RESULTS OF THE 2016
ELECTION.
THEY WERE LET DOWN BY FOUR
SEPARATE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION'S,
THEY WERE COUNTING ON
ROBERT MUELLER TO DO THIS FOR
THEM, NOW THEY ARE GOING TO DO
IT THEMSELVES AND MAKE IT UP AS
THEY GO.